he's a rapper record producer and
songwriter he's the best-selling artist
of the 2000s in America and Rolling
Stone magazine ranked him as 83rd on
their 100 greatest artists of all time
list he sold more than 172 million
albums making him one of the
best-selling artists of all time
he's mmm and here his top ten rules for
success the first time I grabbed the mic
like though like in front of actual
people that mattered
you know silently get it at a club I got
boo I remember that was very traumatic
for me and I'd actually I think I at
that point like the 8-mile thing was
coming right when I bright you're taken
from or whatever so I just remember that
being so dramatic and I think I went on
like man up I quit right and then you
know maybe a couple days later week
later hour later whatever I don't know I
just I got the Earth's like no man I
gotta I gotta get up gotta do it again I
don't think that my goal has changed in
a sense of you know from from just from
from this idiot I rap from the same
aspect of when I did when I was a kid
like I just wanted to get the respect I
just wanted to get a reaction out of
people I just wanted to be heard and I
wanted people to respect what I do and
respect the fact that I respect the
craft that I mean of him seeing so I
really just kind of this kind of is
pretty much the same thing today hip-hop
has always been about bragging and
boasting and I'm better than you with
this and I'm better than you with that
and I finally found something that yeah
this kid over here you know he may have
more chicks like he may have better
clothes or whatever but he can't do this
like me you know I mean he can't write
what I'm writing right now and it
started to feel like you know maybe
Marshalls get a little respect I think
one of my greatest inspirations or
things that our feed off of basically
was just obviously people not believing
in the you know the cloud of doubt they
kind of I felt hung over my head
and wanted to just prove everybody wrong
you know what I mean I wanted to make it
and I was gonna make it regardless of
what anybody said I don't know how we
describe my flow I think that uh develop
the flow from so many other different
artists like I was inspired by letters I
had to say like early on ll Beastie Boys
when DMC and it became you know and
Rakim and kind of started running - uh
maybe Kool G Rap Kara's run
Treach from Naughty by Nature so I had
him you know I was a student at hip-hop
so I was like I just I watched I study
with everybody get in a game and just
you know try to develop my own kind of
sound and it took me a long time to get
but you know I just kind of watch what
everybody was doing was kind of sponge
and soak up anything don't be afraid to
try whatever even if it the idea in the
beginning is stupid yeah you know
because a lot of ideas and beginning
stages not mine of course mine are just
insane from the moment I think of them
course but sometimes ideas you know
they're not always the greatest ya know
I mean you know be afraid to fail
basically to get somewhere else to get
on the journey absolutely yeah so if you
say one thing that's gonna spark another
thing to lead to a better thought yeah
like always with anything you gotta take
the good with the bad
you know you might I understand it did
it that the level of success that I'm at
doesn't happen to everybody every day
but like you know there's there's new
problems you're gonna have with with
with everything if it wasn't my success
and I was still trying to look for a job
or working a dead-end job and didn't
have no money to eat with it would be
those kind of problems that I would have
those type of family problems
how we gonna feed Haley how we going to
raise her how are we gonna stay together
how are we gonna pay our rent Joan I
mean so it would be so now it's new
problems it's like money's not the
problem
now it's different things for other
people interfering in our lives and our
business and like that so you got to
take the good with the bad
well I definitely think that people have
seen me
you push boundaries and maybe you know
some people get inspired to do the same
thing I got that from other people you
know mean like hip-hop has always been
about seeing and feeding off of you know
getting inspired from other MCS in the
game everybody gets inspired from
everybody you know and but I saw Dre do
it you know I'm saying in NWA and the
way that they push boundaries and it was
kind of like you know it's every few
years there will be certain rappers
that'll come along and do that and you
know some some tend to do it better than
others that push it further than others
I was reserved and I was shy and had it
in me but wasn't quite sure how to bring
it out yet I wanted people to hear me so
bad I wanted to do my bit but it was
like you know them jitters and them I'm
scared I'm not scared
I hope struggle and everything
especially early on for me which I love
being on stage and stuff like that once
I got a mic I was cold but it was that
prompted me to do it and get up there
and not be scared to grab that and just
and just rock I feel like anybody can do
anything in set their mind to it depends
on how bad you want it and I wanted to
do it you know the stage of my life I I
don't feel like there's too much that I
can't do oh man you sound cocky but if I
was like really really want to do it I
don't give up that easy
you know back there if somebody would
call somebody out on the mic and I think
I ever called anybody out
I always got called out you know I'm
saying you know they somebody had a mic
in the old and the white boy over there
can get it too so do do me break me down
like how would you break down an emcee
I'm gonna give you a pass to break me
down if I was an emcee just stuff in
that you like this you know if you was
MC and you would caught me out yeah well
it would depend on a probably depend on
what what you what I said what you said
to me in order for me to throw it back
but I'll say top of the head Slim Shady
we could in the ankles on the elderly
lady take it in a mannequin posing that
old Navy
screw it I'm a change your name
introducing slim Brady then I would say
to you off the top of your head it's not
at the top of your head I take the
turbulence the top of your head if you
flat on the ground dead yo I'm number
one in that suit right there is the 1981
and first of all you don't want to step
to me look at your shoes dog they're
broken and broken in you look at your
gear you get them not here I don't want
to have it here take another beer go
take a sip here go sit down
do yourself a favor because dog you're a
clown but I just got laid by em and then
did you know the best part about it was
no matter what somebody said to the next
person you shake hands you know I'm
saying and then it was it was all love
you thank you guys so much for watching
I made this video because Daria but each
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
hear which of Eminem's
top ten rules most resonated with you
leave a comment below and I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon